they build Jessie from Central Texas
what are some of the reason do you think
extraterrestrials will come to earth and
how should we react to them and how do
you think we will react to it and on top
of that what are some of the
consequences things like organized
religion will have when they eventually
make it here vice versa yeah Jesse I
kind of thought that's where you're
going when you started with the aliens
coming from some other world and then
well how does that you think religions
will like react I guess it depends on
the religion the current Pope is going
to roll with it he's going to send
Vatican scientists out there to take a
meeting with them and they'll speak
Latin or whatever the heck but I I know
what you're driving at do you want to
think about this Jesse talking about
extraterrestrials you say you what's
going to happen when they visit I don't
think they're going to visit however
very reasonable that we will in Carl
Sagan fashioned detect the signal excuse
me from some other star system that's
very reasonable
I make no guarantees it's the
christmas-light problem the holiday
light problem where the lights are
blinking our light of being able to
receive X electromagnetic wave from
another civilization has to be on when
another blinking civilization light is
on so that we can cross paths not only
in space but in time we have to have
both civilizations existing at the same
time and with the universe that's at
least thirteen point six billion years
old it's not necessarily a given thing
that everybody will be there lights will
be on at the same time and if you want
to think about this Jesse and religions
it's very reasonable absolutely not
proven we have them we may have the
means to prove it very reasonable that
you and I are descendant of
extraterrestrials
we just found liquid water on Mars super
salty water on Mars that flows every
apparently flows every Martian year
every every time Mars goes around the
Sun and gets warm enough in this one
area liquid
water flows for a while brainy water
evaporates very reasonable that there's
something alive on Mars was certainly
that there was something alive on Mars
then it's very reasonable that Mars was
hit with an impact what you can show
that Mars was hit with an impact or
comet or asteroid about three billion
years ago and some of the material of
Mars was thrown off into space and some
of it landed here we find rocks on earth
that are clearly a Martian origin I
bought one online for kicks and suppose
some especially robust Martian micro but
Mars krob was in this piece of material
landed on Earth and an especially
fertile time here on earth three billion
years ago and you and I are descendants
of Martians do to to to to to to to and
one of the things you mentioned religion
and you mentioned that you're in Texas
I'll just say I did this debate with
this guy in Kentucky who has been very
outspoken that he thinks NASA National
Aeronautics and Space Administration is
wasting tax dollars looking for life
elsewhere because he as near as I can
tell believes that he has a book written
50 centuries ago translated into English
translated many times he believes that
what's in this book overwhelms
everything that we can observe and
record and and infer about nature so I
guess it depends on the religion how
religions will react when we discover
life on another world or we receive a
signal from another civilization as a
cool question man carry on